[Music]
hi
everyone um i'm jen hecht and i'm the dp
of
people operations at our studio and i'm
thrilled to be on stage today with some
folks
we're going to help us talk about
building a career in data science
in particular around the use of r but
not exclusively r
so let me just introduce the panelists
that we have today
sitting right next to me we have sadika
watson uh
she's the founder at coralasi data
insights
and also senior data scientist at
illicit insights
we have david kais who's the founder of
r for the rest of us and we also have
uh gabby de kiros a senior engineering
and data science manager at ibm
and also founder at ai inclusive and
our ladies so uh welcome
very cool
so uh i thought we'd get started by
asking each of you to talk a little bit
about
your own experiences sort of growing
your career in data science
you know we've heard i think a few
panelists today or speakers today talk
about
you know what is it to be a data
scientist i just heard uh
talk about salary structures and i think
it's a topic that's relevant for a lot
of people in different ways
um i'm interested in hearing a little
bit about you know
how did each of you experience
milestones in your data science career
or
perhaps if you're a team manager or
somebody working with people that are
learning
as data science how do you think about
like what are the stages of this and how
do you how have you moved through them
all right ava hello
can you hear gabby hello
okay
all right all right this one is working
cool
so uh let me just like summarize kind of
like my career
path because it's interesting and
different from all of us here
so i was in academia for
about five years doing research with air
pollution data
so then i moved to the industry so
i had this transition point where i'm
like i want to try something else
i want to go to to work for a company so
then i became a data scientist so
i was a statistician before doing
research and then i became a data
scientist
also i moved to san francisco so
statisticians in san francisco they all
became data scientists
so i was first working for a startup
and then doing some kind of like
consulting
um and then i moved to a different
startup
and then became a lead data scientist
and then moved again
senior data scientist moved again became
a developer advocate
and then i got to a point an opportunity
to become a manager
so it's kind of like i don't know like
exactly what other like
you know you wait two years and then you
did this it's kind of like it's when i
felt ready
and i think becoming a manager was a big
jump from all the other transitions that
i had to go through
so i felt like i think i'm ready to
become a manager let's see how it goes
yeah okay great
hi um so my path into data science
definitely has not
been linear particularly because
my motivations my
just thoughts about who i want who i was
and what i wanted to
become and the types of things i wanted
to do they changed so
so for example when i was in high school
i thought
i love math the people that i see around
me in high school
are my math teachers they love math and
they became math teachers and so i'll be
a math teacher you know so
and then at some point i discovered that
there were some other things beyond
education that you could do with math
and heard about
being a math professor you know and then
found out about biostatistics after i
became interested in that type of career
so i ended up
becoming a biostatistics researcher and
then you know as
other people have drank that same data
science kool-aid
heard about all of the cool projects and
the great salary structures
associated with data science and decided
that that was something that i wanted to
do so
some of it was just exposure where
people told me about other different
types of paths that i might not have
thought about
and some of it was just also just
restlessness change and interest
maybe i was really happy with my career
as a biostatistician for the most part
nobody had a i didn't have a problem
with my co-workers or the work but it
was just
i kind of want to see what else is out
there you know and i keep hearing about
this other thing so let me just try that
that's great can you hear me
yeah okay um so first of all i i should
say i think my
uh current work as well as my path is
pretty different from the other folks on
this stage
um unlike them i work for myself um
my business as jen mentioned is art for
the rest of us and i
primarily focus on training folks to use
r
and i particularly focus i think of it
as kind of like people who are scared
about r but want to learn it
that's kind of my niche and how i got
into it
um i think i it's very much by accident
which i know is a story that resonates
with a lot of folks here
um i'm actually trained i'm i'm not very
quantitatively trained i
have a phd in anthropology my
dissertation was entirely qualitative
worked on some mixed methods projects
kind of butted or not butted up against
but
came in contact with some folks who are
using r but never actually used r in
grad school
it was actually only when i started
doing some
consulting work where i was doing what's
called program evaluation work
um looking at kind of applied social
science research looking at the impact
of programs run by nonprofits that type
of thing
and the the organization i was working
for allowed me to use whatever software
i wanted to
so i taught myself r and
basically since then i realized that
there was a need for other people
in that industry as well as others to
learn r
um and so i have kind of made that my my
thing
um but now i forgot what your original
question was
so if you want to well i we were free to
divert from my original question but i
think you know
and that's uh it's been interesting to
hear all the stories i think one theme
is that it's
it's non-linear it's not like there's a
set of uh predefined steps or ladder
you got to do this before you move on to
the next thing um
you hit on something though when you
were talking about having to teach
yourself
and not feeling like you were already
part of a community that was
very quantitative in nature and i think
that's another
question i had for all of you how did
you
build that kind of community whether you
were in industry when you're
learning or you're coming out of
academia kind of go out and find it for
yourself
i know all of you in your own ways have
been involved in trying to bring other
people through that journey but
can you talk a little bit about how you
started to find
that for yourself and and how that
evolved
yeah so uh i didn't have this community
before
uh back in brazil so when i moved over
here and created our ladies that was one
of the intentions
it's like i don't have a community so
i'm going to create it
so that's how it worked for me
i um i so i
i could answer this question in two
different ways according to the period
of
of my life that it relates to so in the
earlier periods of course where
i'm new to the different types of
mathematical concepts and different
statistical
i guess i didn't mention this before so
my background is in math and statistics
so i have a bachelor's in math a
master's in math
a master's in statistics and a phd in
statistics and no student loans yay
and so all of those different types of
educational experiences put me into
different types of environments where
i've got a particular mix of students a
particular set of faculty who are trying
to
you know together help me to learn what
i need to learn
from whatever that perspective is and so
in some sense that community was
curated for me just as just because of
where i was
in school but one thing that i've
noticed
as a professional is that you don't
always have the benefit of having those
readily made communities sometimes you
just have to either create your own
community
as our esteemed panelists did for our
ladies i'm also on our ladies dallas
chapter organizer as well so definitely
understand the value
of those but sometimes you have to be
just very comfortable
being a community of size one right um
and especially in period places where
maybe you're the only one who cares
about data or you're the only one who
cares about r or whatever this new model
or
tool is or whatever where you're either
internally motivated and you're just
reading and going online looking at
blogs or you know different types of
user groups
or you're also just going out finding
meetup groups
finding different types of organizations
just to connect with people who have
similar interests to you
um so i i think it helps to develop
yourself
internally and also externally
and for me i think the answer is
actually pretty straightforward um
online communities and particularly
twitter have been really fundamental in
terms of
um my learning of r i mean i i
can say without reservation that i've
learned more about are from twitter than
any other single source
but also finding a community and
building connections with folks i mean
i've met so many folks here
who i you know have known through
twitter
um and i i've only used art for three
years
um you know only really kind of got more
involved with this community in the last
couple years
um the major benefit if you're not
already aware
um of the twitter community our
community in general is that it's
extremely welcoming
um and so i know i felt coming into it
like i'm an anthropologist i'm not
um you know i don't have much
quantitative background am i going to be
accepted and i have found
i've never not felt accepted i think
because there's such a diversity of the
things that people
do with are everyone and a number of
other reasons including
strongly the work of of our ladies have
made the art community extremely
welcoming
and so i think putting yourself out
there in that community even when you
feel like you know who am i to
try and have anything to say about you
know the world of our when there's so
many people doing so many amazing things
it is such a welcome community and it is
really um
possible to find a place in it that's
great i'm i'm smiling because i've had
so many conversations with people here
and
i think almost everyone feels that way
you know
one of the great things about coming to
the conference is you get to hear
amazing presentations from people doing
cool things but i think the dark side is
people may be wandering around going oh
and the one that doesn't fit so
um i have one other prepared question
and before i ask it i want to just let
people know
you can ask questions for a panelist on
slido i think this is probably pretty
routine for folks now
we're in track one and the the code is
hexagon
so this is a pretty general question but
let's make a let's make a broad
assumption that a lot of people in the
room
are maybe in the earlier stages of their
data science career
um if you had like a few minutes
to spend with them and give them advice
about how to grow that
in a in a the best way possible what
advice would you share with people
so i can start um so my background
i mentioned that i actually went to
school
for statistics and actually went into a
biostats career
and that was before i even knew what
data science was so
when i learned what it was i realized as
especially as i started looking through
some of the different
job opportunities that they would ask
for this long list
of skills right and it was very
intimidating and we need a person who
knows this
and they know this and know this and it
was just how can i
get that expertise so that i can just
get my foot in the door into this first
roll
and so that would be one thing that i
would advise you to
um to think about is to you know just
not be overwhelmed just think about some
of the key
um principles i guess that i would say
are
fundamental to data science and you know
i could list it out as a bulleted list
if you want to write them down
i would say that there are three key
areas of data science that you'd want to
have some proficiency in
um one would be there's obviously the
mathematical component
so there's where your machine learning
or maybe even your deep learning your
clustering algorithms all those kinds of
different algorithms
even logistic regression ordinary least
squares regression basic data analysis
those types of areas are very important
to get some proficiency in
the next would be programming so
obviously having proficiency in
something like r
or python some type of general use
language
such as one of those is ideal
not just understanding specifics of how
to use this
package in that module but knowing how
to program
right how to be a programmer um
how to actually do the loops and if then
statements and actually
put together some piece of code that
accomplishes some tasks
so that'll be the second thing and the
third i would say would be the big data
technologies so some of you might be
familiar with sql
or hadoop spark hive things in that
ecosystem
so having some familiarity at least on
the surface level in each of those three
areas and then developing those more and
more over time
as you get into whichever specific role
and you learn the specific needs of that
role i think that would be a good place
for you to start
thank you yeah
i agree with like the the job
descriptions
and all that but i think if you are
beginner even like big data like
some companies they are not there yet
and they are still on the excel
spreadsheet csv files so like
if big data is like a big thing like
you you are not there yet don't worry
because i i still think there are some
several companies that are still doing
small data working with small data
um but yeah the job job description is
like
don't don't even bother to to learn all
the technologies because like
ah there is no way like i have no idea
like
how people know all that that the
unicorn right so like
the companies they want the unicorn and
you as a data scientist
you don't have to know everything
because if if they are looking for the
unicorn
and you are the unicorn you are probably
not going to work for that company
you're going to be working for a
different company i don't
so if you are trying to get into the
data science
i would say you know apply for jobs
you are going to feel that you are not
ready and that's a feeling that
you are going to have forever you are
never ready
right so just apply apply apply apply
and try to get a sense of like how the
interview processes are because they
vary
so much like some companies are going to
be
asking questions around probability
other
companies are going to ask you questions
more like general like
just to get your thinking you know how
you think about the problems
so i just say if you are looking for a
job just just
just apply don't wait because you will
never be ready
so my answer will be very much tailored
to my work which is
basically as a consultant i think
i would offer two pieces of advice um
one is to try and find a niche if you
are thinking about trying to do some
consulting um
i mean the advantage or one of the major
advantages of ours it's multi-faceted
right you can do so many different
things with r and as
as an our user you know that and you get
very excited um
i think i've found in the with the
consultants or with
as a consultant working with folks um it
can be overwhelming to come in
um i do because i do training and then i
also sometimes actually will do some
work for
folks you know i'll get really excited
and i'll say well we can do
this and our and that and our and this
in you know these 10 other things
um and that can be overwhelming for
folks and so i think really kind of like
trying to focus on
what you can particularly offer to a
client if you are thinking about doing
some consulting so for example i focus
um when i'm not training i mostly do
data visualization because that's an
area
that i'm pretty strong in um so having
that niche i think is important
um the why totally blanked on what my
other thing was
um i will come back to it if i remember
okay cool i'll just add that in my
experience working in hr
most job descriptions are terrible
though
honestly like especially in data science
you know half the things on there
there's no human that could possibly do
it so you shouldn't let that get in your
head
i'll just add that okay so with your
permission
panel i'm gonna go to some questions
from our folks out here
um first one is uh has 30 people asking
this question
i'm trying to decide whether to maintain
a technical role or try to shift into
management and decision making
any tips on what to do if i want to do
both
yeah that's that's a struggle that i i
go through
and be before becoming a manager was the
thing that i was most afraid of
is like am i going to be in this sea of
bureaucracy
and then i'll lose all my technical
skills that i worked
so hard for several years i was
i was not sure so i talked to a few
folks in the company especially the
company that i work for
asking them you know how was your path
and then how do you feel about keeping
up
with the technical piece as well so
in large corporations in particular you
can kind of like
you don't have to go one way or the
other you can kind of
go in the middle and you can also like
always go back and forth
so you can become a manager and go for
the management track but you can also
come back to the technical track for a
few years and then come back again to
the management track
so that's the beauty of like some
companies where you can go back and
forth
so you keep developing
the other thing is try to
you know get some time for you like like
let's say
on fridays i try to schedule no meetings
and then i go to our corner in the room
uh in the office
and then i put my headphone on and then
i just do some coding a code review
so that's my strategy to keep me happy
because there is
a piece of me that i miss if i'm not
doing like technical work
yeah i've definitely been i've had that
that same
fear actually so i was actually kind of
interested to hear what other people had
to say about this
um because i've been invited to go into
management and you know into director
level roles
but i like having my hands on the data i
like
having my finger on the pulse of all the
different types of cool
tools and strategies that are out there
and so i don't want to lose that
so part of me is nervous so i haven't
made that jump
but i would say that something that i
really like those tips
doing things that help you to continue
to
work those muscles so i know some people
who actively had to
go on hacker rank every day and do some
coding exercises in the morning or
um you know actually participate in code
reviews and so on so i would imagine
that would be a really good
good strategy yeah just one thing that i
was thinking now
so if there is anything that i need to
measure like let's say i need to measure
something on my team and then i'm like
yes i have some you know time for me to
create
our shiny where i'm going to measure
something so
i'm trying i try to translate tasks that
i need to do
in a coding exercise so i keep up with
my coding
um yeah
we can talk like it's it's a big jump
it's a big jump for sure it's so
different
but also like you are developing other
pieces of your brand
your skills that is going to help you
also in the future as a coder programmer
so
another example that i was thinking is
one day i had to write something and
then it came
like things were coming through my mind
and i'm like okay
i didn't forget those things and then i
became a better
a better uh searcher or like i don't
know how to say that but like
i i can now search even better because
there is some piece of my brain that got
developed a little bit better so i know
exactly how to look for answers where
before i would struggle
much more so i don't know it's yeah it's
something interesting i think
and if you have the ability to you know
i want to become a manager
i'm going to give like a time uh i'm
going to time box this for two years i'm
going to try it out for two years
is i if i don't like it can i go back
yeah
that's great and david from what you
were saying before you have your hands
in doing direct work as a consultant in
data visualization and your teaching
so you've been able to combine those a
bit as well
and if you work for yourself you get to
do both yeah
better or worse yeah that's great um
okay another very popular question up
here
is can you talk about salary
negotiations any tips
okay i'll start
um so
all right so i'll start with the story
um
something that actually happened so i
was a contractor
working at a company along with a friend
a male colleague who was also a
contractor
um and he ended up deciding to go into
another company
and as they were negotiating his salary
um
he was they asked him you know how much
are you currently making
right which of course is the trap right
because
the next company wants to just kind of
keep you around where you are maybe give
you a little bit more
right and and that is the trap question
that keeps the
the income inequality for men and versus
men versus women um so prevalent um
but he got that question and so he gave
a very creatively high
answer right which i don't necessarily
recommend but
i think he said something like i'm
currently making two hundred thousand
dollars and he wasn't making two hundred
thousand
i'm currently making two hundred
thousand dollars and so the response was
oh there's no way in the world i can pay
you two hundred thousand dollars the
best i could do is 175
is that okay right which to me i would
have never even dreamed of
you know giving some sort of number that
high because i think in a lot of times
we don't value ourselves to be that i'm
not worth 175 thousand dollars you might
be
saying that to yourself well maybe you
know i'll give them a lower number or i
don't want them to think
um that i'm just too greedy or something
like that
so i think what helps um in those types
of situations would be
to first of all understand the market
right understand what a reasonable
amount of money would be for that
particular role for your area
like geographic area and also for your
very your your specialty
and for your years of experience um
and the the worst that they could do is
say no
right i mean you give them a reasonable
number that is in line with
a salary that you can justify the worst
they could say is no it's a little bit
lower
but i definitely just encourage you to
like i said just think a little bit more
outside of the box
and you know value yourselves i guess
maybe higher
than potential because they're they
obviously have a vested interest in
keeping your salary as low as possible
they just want you in the door
in the cheapest way possible so yeah i
highly encourage you to actually
negotiate your salary uh you raise a
great
point about the prior salary that's
really illegal i know it is in
massachusetts now to ask that question
in an interview i don't know how many
other states
have gone there but that's the reason
why is that it automatically kind of
drags
people down especially those who are
unwilling to get creative in their ass
i one thing that i that i kind of
learned to do is you have a network of
people that i have
some kind of like uh open space or open
conversation where i can ask the
questions
you know i can say i'm looking for a job
i've i have this
amount of years of experience and how
much do you think
i should ask for and they say oh you
know i'm a senior person i know that my
company is paying around this
so i kind of like did a survey with like
my my
friends or like the people that i know
and ask them what is the
average or the the interval that you
think i should be
asking for the other good thing and tip
is
if you have any friend that is manager
or hiring manager
ask them because they know a lot about
the salaries
in the industry yeah and the other
thing i would say about that too is and
i want to be careful with this advice
because
if you're working a very conservative uh
industry this
this might be harder to do but you
should be able to talk with your
colleagues in your current job
about what you're making and that can be
very scary
but it's a good way to get information
and i think you know
the workplace is changing a lot one of
the positive things is i think more
transparency
but if you have people that you work
with in your same discipline that you
trust
i'd encourage you to do that even where
you are right now um
and again i i've worked in a range of
places i i think most places are
kind of stopping this practice it used
to be like oh you you cannot discuss
salary which i think also keeps a lot of
people
in the dark about what the real ranges
are
okay i'm going to go to the next
question how do you decide which
technical skills are worth the time
investment to really learn versus having
a passing acquaintance with
i think it would depend on your
your car your specific role and whether
or not
that is something that is needed for
your
job or for your growth so i
think about for example going back to
that list of
that massively long list of different
types of machining machine learning
tools and software and models and all
these different kinds of things
in your particular job maybe you only
need clustering like they need somebody
who's an expert at clustering and they
need somebody who
understands all the different ins and
outs of a very few
you know a very small number of models
um in that sense
you know maybe it's it's worth the
effort of really digging in and
understanding those
and but the other side of that obviously
is that
what that does is it keeps you
[Music]
in the expert role for where you are now
or maybe
with the team that you're currently in
so another view of that will be to say
where do i want to go what is the type
of job that i want to have the type of
career that i want to have for myself
eventually
when i answer that question for myself i
want to be not just the best data
scientist
at my job at my company i want to be the
best data scientist possible so that any
company can look at me
and all the different types of
experiences that i've had and say wow
she really understands
a lot of different kinds of tools she
understands that you know ai for example
that's the buzzword of the of the day
and a lot of companies are interested in
that
and so she's the person that i would
want to call
because she has that type of expertise
so i would definitely challenge you
to think about your career and the path
that you want to
go on and figure out whether or not some
of these different types of tools will
be useful and some of that requires you
know reading in the literature but also
looking at different use cases
to see how other people are using it and
the value that they're able to get from
some of these different types of
tools or models right
this question actually came up in a
session i was in earlier
uh what is the difference between a data
analyst and a data scientist
in your experience is there a difference
so
in some companies there is no
distinction it's it's more like a title
but like from my experience
data analyst is doing more you know
creating the data getting the data from
a database let's say using sql creating
reports
where data scientists go one step
further
where they also do the data cleaning
managing and creating the data but
also is involved on the modeling itself
so that's my experience but i think it's
kind of like a gray area
like some companies they call data
analysts what i consider being a data
scientist
so and they have like different names
yeah even more names than data analysts
and data scientists
yeah it's kind of i mean these are all
squishy terms
you know so i would
i guess maybe just thinking about some
of the different roles i've had
people who've had the data scientists
role they tend to be
[Music]
they tend to have a little bit more
training maybe a little bit more
education
um like formal training um in
maybe like a math or statistics or
physics or something like that
um they tend to again again there's no
there's no hard fast rule for any of
these different types of things
and they tend to have a little bit more
expertise in some of the more advanced
types of
modeling scenarios whereas maybe a data
analyst would be
very proficient in some of the data
engineering tasks or
like pulling different types of sql
queries and maybe creating some
dashboards or some reports
but the the deeper insights of trying to
understand
um maybe maybe starting with a question
of
um why is this why are we losing so much
money
in um this particular area of our
company and this kind of product in our
company
when i think of a data scientist i think
of a scientist right
where you actually have to start from
the beginning nobody's handing you a csv
or telling you specifically which types
of data to look at or what types of
models to use and so
on you're starting from scratch and
you're able to go through that entire
scientific process
and figure out you know where your
hypotheses are
testing those maybe validating those
maybe circling back
and you know going back to the beginning
and so
that entire process i would think of
that as that that person that has that
type of holistic set of skills as a data
scientist as well
and one last thing is data scientists
they usually make much more money
so if you are in doubt if you should
write in your resume that you a data
analyst a data scientist go for data
scientist
that's right yeah it gets complicated
because in some companies there's like
the official job title
that's owned by hr and then they'll let
people make up business titles
uh that say anything you want so i've
seen cases of somebody gets hired as a
business intelligence analyst and three
weeks later they're a data scientist
they're like wow that was fast
okay so uh a good question here
about how do you handle being in a job
with little or no mentorship
opportunities
i kind of touched on this earlier um
there i've definitely been that um
[Music]
how can i say it i've been that person
that has the the set of skills that one
particular set of skills that nobody
else in the company has
so they literally cannot speak to me
about it you know
on some kind of not to say that i'm like
inherently smarter than them necessarily
everybody has their own specialty but
maybe i'm the only one that has studied
this particular area and so
i can't talk to them in that about those
kinds of topics
and so what i have to do is sort of
create my own network
i have just in the course of being
a person who's interested in developing
my network in dallas for example
i go to different events i go to
different talks and you know just talk
to people and find out what they're
interested in
so then when i come up across some kind
of problem and i just like oh i don't
know what to do or
you know where should i go next with
this oh wait a minute david knows this
you know i i know he sounds like the
kind of person that would have that kind
of expertise maybe i can tap him
um so that's one area where it's when
you think about technical mentorship
but the other path would be just growth
for your career
right so just figuring out i want to be
a director someday or i want to be a
technical leader someday how can i
do that right and so some of that is
just finding it finding people who have
gone through that path
that you're trying to to go through and
that could be within your own company
that could be
you know for people who work in similar
types of roles as you're trying to get
into maybe who've
been in different companies so try to
just be creative about finding people
that can inspire you and the ways that
you need that's great
david i'm going to direct this one to
you
can you recommend any good twitter
accounts to follow to learn more about
data and r you mentioned you'd
highly leverage twitter what would you
recommend um
well if you're not only already
following mara avrick that's probably
the best place to start
definitely where i think i've learned
more than anything
um jeez there's so many people how to
um trying to think of some other ones
that have been particularly informative
for me i would say this isn't an account
but the
um in particularly when you're
developing in data visualization
especially the tidy tuesday hashtag has
been really helpful for me
to see folks who are doing some really
interesting data visualization
that's been a helpful one yeah i think
i'd probably start there
great anyone else have anything what
about the our stats
hashtag yeah sorry i assume that was
but yes rsa's hashtag if you're not
already following that
as well the other thing actually
actually looking over
at you for a second gabby makes me think
that um i really like the our ladies
we are our ladies rotating curator
um because it's really fun to see kind
of each week it's a it's a different
person who curates
the account and it's really fun just to
see the different types of work that
people are doing and the different
packages they use so i really like that
account as well
great um so this question is
uh more about like r versus other things
so
i'm fundamentally a generalist in my
overall skills and my r skills breadth
not depth
is that a viable way to build a career
or a specializing essential
for sure
it's valid you're saying yeah no like
this person is saying that
all they know it's r they're saying
they're a generalist and their overall
skills and there are skills
and they're wondering um is that a
viable way to build a career should they
be specializing
within that either in data science or in
our i guess
well i think again there is a broad of
like
jobs so you can be a generalist or you
can be a very specific
it all depends i think there is
maybe you have a better opinion than i
but i think there is space for everybody
for being a generalist and to be a very
like domain expert right right so
um and i think i touched on this a
little bit in the beginning where i was
thinking about the different types of
ways
to classify the different types of
skills that are required
as part of a data scientist and so i was
saying if i wanted to just
be a person that a general
data science company would find
attractive then i would have proficiency
in
machine learning programming and big
data technologies
and as our steam panelists said earlier
some of those companies might not
necessarily care about some of those
right so they might not care about the
big data part maybe they only care about
the other two
but when i think about it again unless
you've already
decided specifically i know that this
job
in particular is what i want and i know
the specific set of skills that are
required for that job and i'm just going
to keep on honing those skills
unless you unless you're doing that i
would challenge you to
branch out a little bit more learn about
other types of things but obviously
don't you don't want to get to the point
where um
you're just picking up every single kind
of tool every diff every type of model
or expertise
at some point you're going to have to
specialize because the people who have
very specific domain experience like
baseball
like you know telecommunications and so
on they really understand the data
so they can go beyond just saying i
understand that this
column seems to be related to discount
they really understand all the different
ways that
that extra knowledge can inform how well
you can get some insights from some of
those different types of projects so
i would encourage you for your specific
area you know once you've actually
determined that there's a specific area
that is of interest to you
that you learn you take the time to
develop that domain experience
and um the good thing about it is that
if you get into it and you realize
i kind of thought i would like this but
i don't like it so much right then you
can get experience in something else
right so you just
um yeah just try different different
things but i definitely would encourage
you to have some type of specialization
in some
some areas great
we have a couple of questions sort of in
this topic gary about
how you have dealt with being perhaps
the only or first woman or person of
color in your organization
or team do you have any advice for
people who might be
in addition to trying to get into data
science also dealing with
issues in that area so i have been in
that
scenario from the woman and also the
person of color scenario
and so many of the roles that i've been
in actually i want to say
every role that i've been in um and uh
yeah and so um some
one of the things that happens commonly
is that
as the one person you feel like you have
to be the representative right
if i mess up then now all black people
mess up
right you know that's just how we are
all women mess up right
so some things you just kind of have to
forgive yourself and realize that you're
human just like everybody else you make
mistakes just like everybody else and
just
you know take those as growing
opportunities to get better
but some of some of the the challenges
are external some of them are internal
so i definitely would just encourage you
to
you know realize you know yeah i'm a
good person too i'm very smart and
you know i have a lot of great ideas and
good things to offer and
um so just kind of keep that in mind as
you're growing your career
yeah also like don't feel like you have
to be the one responsible like let's say
uh there is no diversity efforts and
then you are going to be the one doing
the whole work
because so like try to get other people
to help you as well to have allies
and also the outside network is very
important on those
times so you don't feel lonely so we
have this support
around you that keeps you going
great so
i mean all of you had such different
paths but we have a question here about
for a young data scientist trying to get
their first job should they be looking
at large companies or startups do you
have any
specific advice about what context might
be the best place to start
so i came
so i always worked for startups until
moving to ibm
two years ago almost two years ago so i
went
from a company where we were 20 people
to like
300 000 uh it's a big jump
i don't know what is better i think if
you are a beginner
the best company is the company where
you're going again you're going to have
support mentorship
because it's so hard to break into this
you know career without having someone
mentoring you
so if there is a startup that you have a
good network and support
yeah go for it but if you have
opportunity to work for a big company
you probably have more mentorship but
also like you are going to be more
specialized than a startup
where you do you have to do everything
from
getting the data cleaning the data data
engineering to modeling and putting
production
for example yeah can i also just give a
pitch for the idea of potentially
considering consulting
because i think it's a really good way
that you can gain experience
and you know even if your ultimate goal
is to become say a data scientist i
think there are a lot of opportunities
to use the types of skills that you have
as an r
user um you know outside of that that
title
um in ways that can really be impactful
for the organizations
that you work for i mean just as a as a
minor example
um one of the clients that i was
training recently
was working doing an evaluation of um
an after-school program and they were
working at a hundred different schools
and they had to produce literally a
hundred reports
i taught them about parameterized
reporting and it just like completely
blew their mind the idea that they could
you know automate that not have to
manually produce 100 reports
they're not a data science firm that you
know that's not how they
identify themselves but those types of
skills can can be really useful and
serve a wide variety of organizations
and you can do that sometimes through
consulting i
actually have a follow-up question
directed to you david on that point
which is
how did you get started consulting how
did you start out finding clients and
how has that changed over time
um so i started out consulting um the
honest answer is because i had
twins three and a half years ago and i
wanted more flexibility um
than in the job that i had at the time
um
i started out finding clients i've
mostly done online marketing
um i i offer online courses as well as
trainings for organizations
um and i've tried to basically become
a resource for for other folks so i
write a lot of blog posts really pitched
like newcomers you know learning about
packages to make
effective tables or that type of thing
and that's really been my most effective
strategy to reach out to clients
that's great so i think we're right at
time um
so i'd love to give a round of applause
to the panelists
[Music]